you're going to learn how to say I don't
know the right way and maintain your
credibility in the process so here's a
situation I've seen numerous times a
professional shares some important
information at a group meeting or
someone is in a public speaking
situation all is going well so far but
once the question and answer period
starts somebody asks a question and the
speaker doesn't know the answer and they
fall apart they look like a deer stunned
in the headlights of a car they act like
they've been caught and they are very
hesitant to say the words I don't know
but sometimes that's exactly what you
should say saying I don't know is always
better than faking it and attempting to
BS your way through the answer if you
try to make something up or swerve
around the answer people will notice and
it'll almost always cost you some
credibility but don't worry I'm going to
show you exactly how to say I don't know
and you're going to be so smooth by the
end of this video nobody will even
notice you didn't know I first learned
these basic tips that we'll share when I
worked for a longtime Mentor Alan Wier
I've mentioned him in a lot of videos
he's the author of so smart but how
intelligent people lose credibility and
how they can get it back we're going to
use the slice method in this video The
First Slice is for beginners the second
slice is an intermediate version and the
third slice is for advanced application
and it is smooth as silk slice one is
the biggest slice in the video when you
don't know the answer to a question
especially in that group situation there
are three acceptable ways to say I don't
know one perfectly acceptable answer
that will help you maintain your
credibility is to say some version of I
don't know but I will look into it and
get back to you or I don't know but I'll
find out and follow up I've seen this
done a thousand times from really
confident speakers that's how they do it
now the key with all of these is that
you have to maintain your composure
don't hesitate or act embarrassed so if
somebody asks you a question and you
don't know the answer but perhaps you
should know the answer based upon your
role you just pause think for a moment
and then simply reply with some version
of I don't know or I'm not sure but I'll
look into it and come back to you
shortly we're still talking about slice
one and the next way to say I don't know
is to then refer them to somebody who
does know the answer there are many
situations where somebody may ask you a
question that is genuinely outside of
the scope of your job or outside of the
realm of information that you just
delivered in your present ation you're
not expected to know everything just
because they're asking you but if
there's someone around that you could
refer them to that's the expert who you
want to point them towards and it sounds
like this I don't know but Gary should
have that information or I don't know
but I would refer you to Gary who works
in that department a couple of points of
clarification about this one you want to
be sure the person you are mentioning
really does know the answer or at least
they should know the answer better than
you do your best to identify the right
person person for the job in other words
and if the person is in the room at the
time that's fantastic now on the one
hand they can answer the question right
there and then on the other hand make
sure you don't throw them under the bus
or blame them for anything so refer to
them in a supportive and in a
conversational way if somebody asked you
a question and you believe that Gary
might be the right person to answer it
you would say respectfully is Gary here
Gary would you like to answer that
question and the third way to say I
don't know and maintain credibility is
to tell them what do know I learned this
tip from an old consultant friend of
mine Joe jackowitz so thank you Joe
there are many occasions where you'll be
asked a question that is slightly off
focus or may reflect the other person's
agenda a little too much their question
may not be as relevant as they're making
it sound in the moment in other
instances they may be asking you for
data or information that simply doesn't
exist or doesn't exist yet or you don't
have access to it in situations like
this you would say I don't know but
here's what I do know or here's what I
can tell you and then you give them the
best information that you have that at
least somewhat addresses their concern
so let's say for example somebody asks
you about the exact sales figures for
the quarter that just closed and you
don't know the answer to that you might
say I don't know the exact numbers but I
have heard it was our strongest quarter
in 2 years if someone asks how many
people were there last night you could
say I don't know how many but I can't
tell you it was packed and there was a
line out the door you notice in my
examples I'm not trying to be
argumentative or change the subject I'm
not trying to dodge the question I just
don't know the exact answer so I try to
give them something that's valuable that
corresponds to their underlying concern
or question that's when you use this
option I don't know but here's what I do
know or here's what I can tell you so
far that was all slice one the biggest
slice of the video now let's move on to
slice two which is an intermediate way
to answer use this approach if you simp
simply want to avoid saying the actual
words quote I don't know for some reason
maybe you don't like how it sounds or at
least you don't want to say it
repetitively if people ask you multiple
questions if that's the case there are
lots of other ways to say that that
sound a little better but are still
honest here are some other ways to say
it I haven't seen any data about that
yet or I can't be certain because and
then fill in the reason or we'll have
that answer by and then give them a time
estimate I'd have to confir before I
comment on that I don't have that answer
right now but and then you would give
them whatever answer you did have in
fact I'll bet as you're watching this
right now you've probably heard other
ways to say I don't know that sound
pretty good to your ears so I have a
request do all future viewers a favor of
this video and suggest an alternative
wording that sounds good to you without
saying I don't know sounds supportive it
sounds honest put your suggestions in
the comments below for everybody to see
now here's what to do with these
alternative phrases if you have an
upcoming presentation or group meeting
and you anticipate some Q&A and you may
not know the answer practice a few of
these alternative ways to say I don't
know alloud have them in your back
pocket now I recommend practicing them
out loud so they sound fluent and
confident coming out of your mouth in
the moment slice two is a little more
advanced than slice one because you
don't directly say I don't know but
you're still being honest and truthful
using different language may help you
save face a little bit in the moment and
project confidence as you answer and you
can follow up any of those phrases Again
by saying I'll follow up with you refer
them to somebody else who does know or
tell them what you do know and now for
slice three this is a little more
advanced but you can use this advice
fairly quickly with a few minutes of
practice on slice one and two and here's
the tip for helping you sound as smooth
as silk skip over the part of the
sentence that says I don't know
altogether and just say the second part
of your answer here are some earlier
examples and we're just going to leave
off the statement I don't know and say
the second part you'll see that with
some minor adjustments in your wording
this will still work great in most
situations I'll have to look into that
information and get back to you I'll
find you that answer and follow up Gary
should have that information I would
refer you to Gary who works in that
department if Gary is here he's the best
person to answer that
I know that it was our strongest quarter
in two
years I can tell you it was packed and
there was a line out the door and the
reason this approach works is that
you're still doing your best to help the
other person it's not a Dodge we may not
know the answer but we're still trying
to provide an answer that will give them
some helpful information or at least
Point them in the right direction so
even though this entire video is about
how to say I don't know and maintain
credibility there are ways to give an
honest answer without having to always
say the actual words every time I cannot
emphasize enough that even though we're
really talking about just the words you
say in this video your conversational
tone your positive and professional
attitude will go a long way to
projecting confidence and credibility
regardless of which of these three
slices you use as you practice this on
your own be sure to combine the right
words with the right attitude in other
words until next time thanks God bless
and I'll see you soon